Okay Michael, so that was pretty good with the quiz. I want to
do another derivation and I want you to help me with it, okay?
>> Hm. Cool.
>> Okay, so Michael, we have a similar
setup to what we've had before. We're given a
bunch of training data, XI inputs and DI
outputs. But this time we're dealing with real valued
functions. So the way DIs are constructed is
there's some Deterministic function f, that we pass the
fs through. And that gives us some value.
And that's really what we're trying to figure out.
What is the underlying f? But to make our job
a little bit harder, we have noisy outputs. So, for every
single DI that is generated, there's some small error, epsilon
that is added to it. Now, this particular error term, is
in fact drawn from a normal distribution with zero mean
and some variance. We don't know what the variance is. It's
going to turn out. It doesn't actually matter. There's some variance
going on here. The important thing is that there's zero mean.
So, you got it?
>> And it's important that it's probably the same variance for all the data.
>> That's right, in fact, each of these epsilon sub i's are drawn iid.
>> And is that f, are we assuming it's linear?
>> Nope, we're not assuming that it's linear.
>> Okay.
>> It's just some function.
>> All right, I'm with you.
>> Okay, so you got it?
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, here's my question
to you. What is The maximum likelihood hypothesis.
>> Do we know f? Can I just say f?
>> No,
we don't know f. All we see are x sub i's and d sub i's. But we
know there is some underlying f. And we
know that it's noisy, according to some normal distribution.
>> I don't know how I would find that.
>> Well let's try to walk it through. So.
We know how to find the maximum likelihood hypothesis, at
least we know an equation for it. The maximum
likelihood hypothesis is simply the one that maximizes this expression.
>> Right. That was when we assumed a uniform
prior on the hypotheses.
>> Exactly. And so we, this is sort of the easiest
case to think about Where it turns out that finding the
hypothesis that best fits the data is the same as finding
a hypothesis that describes the data the best. If you make an
assumption about a uniform distribution, or a uniform prior. Okay, so.
This is all we have to do now is figure out
what we're going to do to expand this expression. So what do
you think we should do first? The probability of the data given
the hypothesis. Right. So each we assumed IID.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You actually helpfully even wrote that down.
So we can expand that into the product
over all the data elements of the probablity
of that data element given the hypothesis. And x.
>> Okay, so let's do that, Michael.
Let's write that out. So, finding the hypothesis
that maximizes the data that we see, as you point out, is just a product
over each of the independent data that we
see. Or datums. So that's good. That's one
nice step. So we've gone from talking about
all of the data together to each of the
individual training data that we see. So what
do we do next? What is the probability
of seeing one particular P sub i, given that we're in a world where H is true.
>> So okay, given that H is true that means whatever the corresponding xi
is, if we push that through the f function, then the di is going to
be F of XI plus some error term so I guess if we took di minus
F X I, that would tell us what the error term is and the we
just need an expression for saying how likely it is that we get that much error.
>> Right, so, what is the expression that tells us that?
>> I'm guessing it's something that uses the
normal distribution, it probably has an E in it.
>> [LAUGH] I think that' s absolutely right.
So, let's be particular about what you said. So, when
you say that we should push it through F of X,
let's be clear that that's basically what H is supposed
to be. Our goal here is, given all of this training
data, let's recover what the true f of x is.
And that's what our H is. Each of our hypotheses a
guess about what the true underlying deterministic function F is.
So, if we have some particular labels, some particular value D
sub I that is at variance with that. What's the probability of us
seeing something that far away from the
true underlying F. Well, it's completely determined
by, the noise model. And the noise is a Gaussian. So, we can
actually write down Gaussian. Do you remember
what the equation for a Gaussian is?
>> Yes. It's exactly something that has an E in it.
>> That's right. So I'll see, I'm going to start writing it
and you see if you remember any of what I'm writing down.
>> E to the...
>> No.
>> Okay, good.
>> It's 1 over.
>> E to the.
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Square root of, it's, it's coming back to you now. 2 pi sigma squared.
>> Times...
>> I was going to put that in after.
>> Oh, okay. So now you get your E, so E to the what?
>> It's going to be the value, which, in our case, is, like, H of XI
minus DI.
>> Yeah. And then I feel like, we probably square that?
>> Yep.
>> And then we divide by sigma squared?
>> right.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> Sweet!
>> And your missing one tiny thing.
>> There needs to be another two.
>> Yes. And in fact it's minus one half.
>> Got it.
>> So, this is exactly the form of the Gaussian
in the normal distribution. And what it basically says is the
probability me seeing some particular point, in this case D of I. Given
that the mean is H of X. Which is to say
that's the underlying the function. Is exactly this expression. e to
the minus one half, of the distance from the mean, squared,
divided by the merits. Okay. And that's just, you either remember
that or you don't. But that's just the definition of a
Gaussian. So that means the probability of us seeing the data
is the product of the probability of us seeing each of
the data items. And that's just the product of this expression
here. Good. Now, we need to simplify this. We could stop here
because this is true, but we really need to simplify this and
I think it's pretty... Not to hard to do. It's pretty easy.
>> Mm..hm.
>> What kind of trick do you think we would do here to simplify this?
>> So, first thing I would do is, noticed that the 1 over square root 2 pi
sigma square doesn't depend on i at all, and
maybe move it outside the pi but then realize,
well, actually since we're doing an argmax anyway, it's not going to have
any impact at all. [CROSSTALK] I would just like cross that baby out.
>> I like that. No point in keeping it. All right, now I'm
hoping that the other sigma squared we can make that go away too.
So I'm tempted to just cross it out, but I'd rather, I'd be
much more happy if I had a good explanation for why that's okay.
>> Well, so what's the normal trick,
so we're trying to maximize the function,
right? What you just said is we can get rid of this particular constant
expression because it doesn't affect the max.
What's making it hard for you to get
rid of the sigma squared here is that
it's being passed through some exponential and you
can't remember off the top of your head
what clever work you can do with constants
inside of exponentials. So it would be nice
if we could get rid of the exponential.
>> Very good. So because log is concave.
>> No, because it's monotonic.
>> um-hm. We can take the log of the whole shabang. So this is going to
be equal to the argmax of the sum of the log of that expression, which
is going to move the thing to the outside and the log of E, so that's
going to be good, so it's going to be
the sum of the superscript thing, the power.
>> Right. So let's write that down. Okay, so just
to be sure that that was clear to everybody, let's just
point out that we basically took the log of both, the
natural log of both sides, and so we said, instead of
trying to find the maximum hypothesis or the maximum likelihood hypothesis
by evaluating this expression directly, we instead evaluated the log of
that expression. And as you'll recall from intermediate algebra, the log
of a product is the same as the sum of the
logs, and the log of E to something is just that thing.
>> As long as we do natural log.
>> As long as we do natural log when we have E. If we were doing
something to the, 2 to the power of something, we'd want to do log base 2. Okay.
>> Got it. And you said to do it to both sides but we really didn't need to
do it to both sides we just needed to
do it inside the things we taking the argmax.
>> That's correct. Okay, so we've got here. So,
is there any other simplifying that we can do.
>> Yeah, yeah now it seems much clearer
so the. The negative one half divided by sigma
squared all can move outside the sum cause it doesn't depend on I at all.
>> Right. And then the sigma squared you
said that before you said that that wasn't going
to turn out to matter. Both sigma squares ended
up, you know, getting tossed into the rubbish heap.
>> That's right.
>> And I want to be careful with the negative sign. Like I feel like
the half can go and the sigma square can go but the negative has to stay.
>> You're right. The half can go. And the sigma squared
can go. So that leaves us with this expression. So I've taken,
gotten rid of the one half, like you
suggested. Got rid of the sigma squared like you
suggested, and I moved the minus sign outside
of the summation. And I'm left with this expression.
>> I have a thought about getting rid of that minus sign.
>> Well how would you get rid of a minus sign?
>> So the max of a negative is the min. Right, so we can
get rid of the minus sign by
just simply minimizing instead of maximizing that expression.
We end up with this expression.
>> Nice. That's much simpler than where we started. The e is gone.
>> It's much simpler. We got rid of a bunch
of e's. We got rid of a bunch of turns
out extraneous constants. We got rid of multiplication. We did
a bunch of stuff, and we ended up with this.
>> You know, we got rid of two pis. It's kind of sad I would like some pie.
>> Mm, I wonder what kind of pie it was?
>> Pecan pie?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, so we got this expression, and that's kind of
nice on your own you say, but actually it's even nicer
than that.
>> What?
>> What does this expression remind you of Michael?
>> The Sum of Squares.
>> This is exactly it. This is, in
fact. The sum of squared error, which is awesome.
>> Yeah, whoever decided it would be a good idea
to model noise as a Gaussian was really on to something.
>> Mm-hm. Now, think about what this
means, Michael. We just took, using Bayesian Learning,
a very simple idea of maximizing a likelihood.
We did nothing but substitution, here and there.
With the noise model. We got rid of a bunch of things
that we didn't have to get rid of. We cleverly used the natural
log. Notice that the minus sign can be taken away with the
min. And, we ended up with sum of squared error. Which suggests that
all that stuff we were doing with back propagation. And, all these
other kinds of things we're doing with receptrons is the right thing to
do. Minimizing the sum of square error, which we've just been doing
before. Is in fact the right thing to do according to Bayesian learning.
>> Right in this
case meaning meaning what a Bayesian would say.
>> Meaning what a Bayesian would say which I believe
is sort of right by definition. More importantly here it is.
>> They certainly believe it.
>> Well, they, they do frequently.
>> Oh! I see what you did there.
>> No one will get that but, but us. Anyway,
the thing is this is the thing you should minimize if
you're trying to find the maximum likelihood hypothesis. Now, I just
want to say something. That is beautiful. Absolutely beautiful. That you
do something very simple like finding the maximum likelihood
hypothesis and you end up deriving sum of squared errors.
>> So, just to make sure that
I'm understanding. because I see some beauty here,
but maybe not all of it. We didn't talk about what the hypothesis class here
was. Right, so, if you don't know
what the hypothesis class is... You're, you're kind
of stalled at this point, but if we
say the hypothesis class is say linear functions.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then, what we're saying is we can do linear regression,
because linear regression is exactly about minimizing the sum
of the squares, right? So linear regression comes popping out
of this kind of Bayesian perspective just like that, so
is, is that part of what makes it so cool?
>> That is part of what makes it cool, but I
just think more generally about gradient descent right? The way gradient descend
works is you take a derivative by stepping in this, in
this space of the error function, which is sum of squared error.
>> I see, so you get gradient descend too.
>> Yes, you get all of the stuff that people have been doing.
Now, there's a piece of beauty there, which is that we derived
things like gradient descend and linear regression, all of the stuff we
were talking about before and we have an argument. For why it's
the right thing to do at least in a Bayesian sense. But
there's an even deeper beauty here, which is tied in with ugliness,
which is the reason this is the right thing to do, is
because of the specific assumptions that we've made. So what were the
assumptions that we made? We assumed that there was some True deterministic
function that was mapping our x's to our in
this case our d's and that they were corrupted
say transmission error or line noise or however you
want to think about it. They are corrupted by some
noise that has a very particular form. Uncorrelated, independently
drawn, Gaussian noise, with mean zero. So the less pretty
way of thinking about it is. Whenever you're trying
to minimize the sum of squared error, you are in
fact assuming that the data that you have has been corrupted by
Gaussian noise. And if it's corrupted by some other noise, or you're
actually not trying to model determinance function, of this sort. And then
you are in fact, possibly, in fact most likely doing the wrong thing.
>> I mean are there other noise models
that lead to some other kinds of learning.
>> Sure, pick any other model in here that does't look
Gaussian at all, and you would end up with something else.
I don't know what you would end up with because. You
know, you couldn't do all these cute tricks with natural logs but
yes, you would end up with something different. And one question
you might ask yourself is well, if I try to do minimizing
the sum of the squared errors, or something for which this
model was not the right one, what sort of bad things might
happen? Here let me give you an example, let's imagine that we're
looking at this here, and our X's are, I don't know measurements
of people. Okay? So height and weight. Something like that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And in fact let's make it, let's make it
let's make it even simpler than that. Let's imagine that our
x is our height. And our outputs, our d's, are
say weight. And what we're trying to learn is some kind of
function from height to weight. Now, this doesn't make a
lot of sense to have a true [INAUDIBLE], but I'm trying
to make a point here. So what we're saying here is
that we, we measure our height and then we measure weight.
That there's some simple relationship between
them that's captured by f. But, when
we measure the weight, we get a sort of noisy version of that
weight. Okay? That seems reasonable. But
what's not reasonable is we're saying. Our
measurement of the weight is noisy, but our measurement of height is not.
>> Because if the x's are noisy, then this is not a valid assumption.
>> I see.
>> So, it seems to work
a lot of the time and we have an argument for
when it will work, but it's not clear that this particular assumption
actually makes a lot of sense in the real world. Even
though in practice it seems to do just fine. Okay, got it?
>> I think so though I feel like if the error if you put
an error term inside the f along with the x and f is say linear.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Then maybe it pops out and it just becomes another
part of the noise term and, and it all still goes through.
Like I feel lines are still pretty happy even with that.
>> No I think you're right. Lines would be happy here because
linear, I mean linear functions are very nicely behaved in that way.
But of course, they'd have to be the same noise model in
order for it to work the way you want it to work.
>> Yeah.
>> They'd have to both be Gaussian. They have to both have
zero mean, right? And they'd have to be independent of one another.
So your measuring device that gives you an error for your height
would also have to give you an independent normal error for the weight.
>>
Yeah. Though I feel like my scale and my
yardstick actually are fairly independent. And they're Gaussian? .
>> Oh mine is clearly Gaussian.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well at least they're normal.
>> They're normally are.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Okay good. So let's move on to the next thing Michael. Let's try one
more example of this and, and then I hope that means you got it, okay?
>> Sure.
>> Beautiful.